and welcome to Hannity and we begin
tonight with the Fox News Alert We are
following two massive stories tonight
that could Rock the 2024 election first
the long awaited special counsel report
on President Biden's mishandling of top
secret classified documents from his
time as even a senator but vice
president a have now been made public
that report it is beyond damning Biden
just tried to save face with the
American public uh it was a shocking uh
display of his cognitive decline we're
going to play those outrageous remarks
in a minute but let's lay out the
details in this report devastating
according to the report quote President
Biden willfully retained and disclosed
classified materials after his vice
presidency when he was a private citizen
investigators found classified documents
including notebooks from meetings
regarding highly sensitive material on
foreign policy and national secur uh
security carelessly stored in what
appears to be his garage uh and while
what the special counsel found about
Biden's handling a classified documents
was alarming what it says about his
cognitive state is quite frankly
shocking and by the way it should have
every single American concerned about
the mental health the cognitive health
of the president of our country the
president of the United States and
according to the special counsel the
Department of Justice they are not
charging Joe Biden quote because Mr
Biden would likely present himself to a
jury as he did during our interview of
him as a sympathetic well-meaning
elderly man with a poor memory so let me
get this straight does this mean the
special counsel is not charging Biden uh
because of his cognitive decline and
would come off as a nice guy I thought
the special counsel said uh he did this
willfully and by the way it gets much
worse according to the report on the
first day of Biden's interview he could
not even remember when he was vice
president he asked the people
interviewing him uh if it was 2013 when
did I stop being vice president he
couldn't remember when he took office as
vice president asking this question in
2009 am I still vice president and in
what probably is the saddest part of the
entire report and it's sad Joe couldn't
even remember within a few years when
his son Bo died and according to the
special council's findings Biden's clear
cognitive struggles in meetings with his
ghost riter in early 2017 just months
after leaving office as vice president
quote likely appear consistent with the
diminished faculties and faulty memory
and frankly this is scary but now we
have been warning you about this for
years Joe Biden does not have the
cognitive strength and ability and
mental stamina to take on the toughest
job in the world and that's to lead this
country
and I'm not being flippant when I say
this they are describing a president of
the United States who could not be one
of those very nice Walmart greeters
because they would be describing a
person who would be Cog cognitively
incapable of actually remembering where
every department is in the store the
special counsel is saying loudly that
Joe Biden is unfit to be the president
think about the what the rest of the
world is thinking about this report Joe
is in charge of our nuclear weapons he
he's got the nuclear football with him
at all times right next to him and
tonight even the media mob they're
struggling to defend him NBC news
reporting the special council's
assessment of Joe Biden's mental state
has triggered quote Democratic Panic The
Washington Post said the report was
quote paints a scathing picture of
Biden's memory and both the USA Today
recap of the report and the axio right
up pointed to the growing questions
around Biden's memory concerns and the
hill called it quote eyebrow raising
report an eyebrow raising report when
pressed by reporters tonight in a
bizarre press conference only answered
about three questions Biden dismiss
questions about his age and his memory
take a look President Biden something
the special counsel said in his report
is that one of the reasons you were not
charged is because in his description
you are a well-meaning elderly man with
a poor memory I'm well-meaning and I'm
an elderly man and I know what the hell
I'm doing I've been president I put this
country back on his feet I don't need
his recommendation it's totally how bad
is your memory and can you continue as
president my memory is so bad I let you
speak that's that's you know your memory
has gotten worse Mr President my memory
is not good my memory is fine voters
have concerns about your age how are you
going to assuage them and do you fear
that this report is only going to fuel
further concerns about your age only by
some of you for months when you were
asked about your age you would respond
with the words watch me many American
people have been watching and they have
expressed concerns about your age that
is your judgment that is your judg to
that is not the Judgment of the they
express concerns about your mental
acuity they say that you are too old Mr
President in December you told me that
you believe there are many other
Democrats who could deat Donald Trump so
why does it have to be you now what what
is your answer I'm most qualified person
in this country to be president of the
United States and finish the job I
started Peter Ducey will join us in just
a moment a very contentious press
conference probably in in the if we look
at modern history the modern level of
presidency and the people that have
served I can't think of a worse report
or Worse press conference than this one
now Joe if your memory really is fine
then why couldn't you remember the name
of the church your son's Rosary is from
he couldn't remember this is at this
disastrous press conference after the
release of the disastrous report look at
this I know there's some attention paid
to some language in the report about my
recollection of events there's even
reference that I don't
remember when my son
died how in the hell dare he raised
that frankly when I was asked the
question I thought to myself wasn't any
of their damn
business let me tell you
something some of you have commented I
wear since the day he died every single
day the rosary he got from our lady
of every Memorial Day we hold a service
remembering him attending my friends and
family and the people who loved
him our lady
of I'm not making fun he couldn't
remember and that wasn't his only
blunder in the short press conference he
also called the president of Egypt the
president of Mexico that means president
lce take a look the
conduct of the
response in Gaza in the Gaza Strip has
been
um over the
top I think that
uh as you
know initially the president of Mexico
CCE did not want to open up the gate to
allow humanitarian material to get in I
talk to him I convince to open the
gate the president of Egypt is a time to
consider invoking the 25th Amendment now
you may remember section four of this
amendment it authorizes a vice president
a majority of principal officers of the
executive departments to now transmit to
the president protemp uh of the Senate
and the Speaker of the House their
written declaration that the president
is unable to discharge the power and the
duties of his office allowing the vice
president to immediately assume the
powers and duties of the office as
acting president now going back to the
damning report Biden went pressed on why
he took the classified material and this
angry presser declared that the
notebooks are his quote property and
that quote every president before me has
done this exact same thing sound
familiar this is almost the exact same
argument former president Trump made
right here on this show last year months
after investigators conducted their raid
of maral Lago yet he still faces charges
now this is why the house Judiciary they
are rightly investigating whether Joe
Biden's Department of Justice is
weaponized whether or not the doj has
been politicized and tonight after the
release of the report Trump called
called on the special counsel in his
case to dismiss all charges related to
the classified document issue but sadly
what have we learn if you're Hillary
Clinton if you're Joe Biden you get one
system of justice we have a two-tiered
system of justice it's now on full
display once again Hillary Clinton
remember her deleted 33,000 subpoena
emails some with top secret classified
information off her private server she
faced no charges and don't forget we we
know about the top secret classified
documents that James Comey did find but
no reasonable prosecutor would prosecute
now Joe gets off without charges just
like Hillary and James Comey he gets uh
James Comey exonerates Hillary and
Donald Trump gets uh let's see his home
rated and charges brought against him
remember James Comey found tons of
classified email on that on that laptop
top secret classified email it was
believed that our enemies might have had
access to it but first our other top
story tonight we'll get to back to this
in a minute earlier today the Supreme
Court they heard oral arguments this
over the Colorado attempt to ban Donald
Trump from that ballot and it was a
disaster from start to finish for the
leftists in Colorado listen to this if
Colorado's uh position is upheld surely
there will be disqualification
proceedings on the other side I would
expect that uh you know a goodly number
of states will say uh whoever the
Democratic candidate is you're off the
ballot and others uh for the Republican
candidate you're off the ballot and
it'll come down to just a handful of
states that are going to decide the
presidential election that's a pretty
daunting consequence what about the idea
that um we should think about democracy
think about the right of the people to
elect uh candidates of their choice of
letting the people decide because your
position has the effect of
disenfranchising uh voters to a
significant degree the question that you
have to confront is why a single state
should decide who gets to be president
of the United States hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else